[موسيقى]
احنا دلوقتي رابطين الجنيه بالدولار وده
يعني اما تعبير عن قله الحيله او على
الكسر المهني الشديد لابد ان يكون لديك
انت كبلد الشخص المناسب في المقام المناسب
تدي اهميه من الدرجه الاولى للزراعه
والصناعه قطعاني لا ثالث له الباقي يجي
وراهم اللي هم القطار المهملين
وبالنسبه لموضوع الاغلبيه ايضا لازم تحط
اولويات بالنسبه لما يسمى المشروعات
القوميه وانت معتقد انه الخلفيات المصرفيه
لا تصلح لقياده المركزي بسبب تصرف في
الاداره الامريكيه غير مسؤول بتستغل
سلطتها في مجال اصدار البنك نوت للعالم
اللي هو الدولار في انها تؤذي كل خلق الله
المفروض ان ده على الورق مش وحش
الواقع شيء مختلف
مساء الخير على حضراتكم مساء الخير معنا
الدكتور مساء النور عليكم المشاهدين ربنا
يخلي حضرتك احنا النهارده
اه اليوتيوب صحيح في روسيا واوروبا
وامريكا احنا بنحاول نستكمل النهارده مع
حضرتك ما توقفنا عنده وانا عندي سؤال محدد
طبعا الحلقه اللي فاتت احنا اتكلمنا على
تصور الدكتور جوده الى اعاده ان احنا يجب
ان نعيد النظر في
المؤسسات الدوليه اللي بتقدم نفسهم على
انهم شركاء التنميه فيما ان هدفهم الاساسي
وخدمه مصالح الدول الكبيره على حساب الدول
الناشئه والفقيره ودايما مذكور من بين هذه
المؤسسات اللي بتلعب دور يشك فيه كثيرا
الدكتور جوده هو صندوق النقد الدولي وانا
عندي سؤال بسيط
ما مشكله حضرتك مع صندوق النقد الدولي
باختصار لانه ما نسمعه ان صندوق النقد
الدولي بيقول كلام بديهي عيش على قد رجليك
وفر
في نفقاتك وهندي لك دعم تبدا به على امل
ان انت يعني وخفض الدعم وخفض الجنيه
وبيقول كلام يبدو متفقا مع منطق الاقتصاد
العادي طيب شوف انا هبدا من زاويه مختلفه
شويه برضو عشان نعمل اطلاله على الموضوع
وبعدين اجاوب على لما البرتغاليين نكتشفوا
الطريق الى الشرق عبر راس الرجاء الصالح
حيث كان من اهم الحاجات اللي عملوها عملوا
مستعمرات لهم على سواحل افريقيا وسواحل
اسيا كويس كده
وبداوا يدخلوا في تعاملات مع المجتمعات
المحليه
من منطلق انه عايز يروق
لما جاء به فانتقى مجموعه من العناصر من
هذه المجتمعات المحليه وخليها هي المتحدث
باسمه والمروج
واصطلاحا
والشخص اللي مهمته ترويج بضاعه الاجانب
بين بني جلدته
فهنا مشكلتي مع الكمبرودور مش مع الصندوق
اللي بيروجه
بمناسبه انا اسف دي اول مره افهم قصتها
الدكتور سمير امين الله يرحمه كان يقول لي
كومبرادور كتير وانا مش فاهم
في اشاره الى الاقتصاديين اللي بيقربوا
لافكار الصندوق وطبعا دول موجودين نتيجه
يعني تعليمهم في الجامعات يعني فهنا
النقطه طبعا لو قلنا بالرغم ان كل ما يقول
الصندوق منطقي
انه السوق تعلو على الدوله
كاليه لاتخاذ القرار وتخصيص الموارد سهله
مهمه جدا
الملكيه الخاصه لها اولويه على الملكيه
دور الدوله
ان ينحسر بالراء في مجال
تنظيم الاسواق والاشراف على وتقديم
الخدمات المجتمعيه زي الامن والعداله
والدفاع اساسا
ده في المهمل وبالتالي لما انت تواجه ده
الكلام ده الاسياده قالوا لنا كده بعد ما
بنوا نفسهم واصبحوا عندهم اسواق بتعمل
بكفاءه بكفاءه وبنظام
وباقل قدر من
الضحايا عندهم لكن عندنا الوضع مختلف عايز
اقول طبعا ارجو ان يفهم من كلامي ان انا
ابقى ادعو الى قطيع مع الصندوق
لاعتقد اننا حمل قطيع مع الصندوق بامانه
ما ادعو اليه هو ان نتوسل بما ينبغي علينا
ان نتوسل به من الفهم
وتغيير النظره
وقراءه الواقع
واملاء الاراده الوطنيه واحنا بنتعامل اذا
دخلنا بالشروط دي في منفعه التعامل بيننا
مع الصندوق وطبعا في تجارب مثلا انا اعرف
في حاله بلاد زي المكسيكا على سبيل لما
اقدم والبرازيل بتعمل بتقدم تصور وطني
للصندوق
ويبقى الموضوع التصور ده موضوع مفاوضات
سنه كده سنه كده في نهايه بيوصل الاتفاق
انما لما تيجي عندنا لا انا بتابع الكلام
ده مش بتكلم الفراغ على فكره يعني
انا نشرت دراسه
نشرتها قدمتها للنشر هنا فوديتها للناس
يقروها فقال له لا اصل انت راجل يا ساري
ويعني احنا عارفين افكارك قلت لهم شكرا
رحت قاعد حبست نفسي تلات اشهر قعدت كتابه
النص ده بالانجليزي رحت بعته واحده من
اكبر دور النشر في امريكا وانجلترا
المهم لما اتصلوا شحاته وادوا له كتابه
وترجمنا كتاب اللغه العربيه شوف بقى
الماساه بالنسبه لي وحشه جدا يعني اضطر
اكتبه بالانجليزي وبعدين نرجع نترجمه
في النهايه
ولا تلاقي التقديم بتاع دكتور الرينج حرمه
فمن اللي قاله فيه انه دراسه ضوفيه جدا
لعلاقه مصر بالبنك وبالصندوق
ودراسه من بنيه الفكر بتاعهم هم مش بتاعنا
وقال في الكتاب في من النتائج التي يمكن
لمسؤول البنك والصندوق بياخدوها في
الاعتبار ياخدوها في الاعتبار وهم يعني
يتعاملوا مع حالات دول ايه دول شبيهه فانا
بقول موقفي مبني على ان انا يعني عارف
الكيانات دي بتشتغل ازاي
بالتاكيد طبعا اذا انت عايز يعني النقطه
لازم يبقى تبدا من فكره المصلحه الوطنيه
كويس كده وانه بتبحث عن مساحه مشتركه
لا انت تكسب والصندوق يكسب فهنا في مجال
كبير انا شايف من متابعتي ومثلا قلت
بالنسبه لاتفاق 2016
الاتفاق الذي عقدته مصر ليه تحت بند
الاصلاح الاقتصادي لمده ثلاث سنين وحصلنا
بموجبه على 12 مليار دولار
يعني قيل وقتها بوسخ وراء الصندوق وايضا
خبراء الحكومه المشاركين في العمليه ويمكن
الناس مشاهديني يتذكروا قال لك لا لا يعني
تخفيض الجنيه وتعويمه حتمه لا مفر صحيح
انا قلت يا جماعه ليس هناك حتميه في
الموضوع طبعا اذا كنت انت عايز تسهل عمليه
حصول الاجانب على الاصول الانتاجيه بتاع
المصريين بابخس الاسعار يبقى التعريف
الموضوع يعني توقف انت عايز ايه لما اذا
كنت عايز تبني بلد واقتصاد وتعين شعب على
انه يعيش حياه
حياه كريمه طبعا طبعا مصطلح المتداول
يبقى لا وقدمت بديل كل الهوسه دي اعملها
على اساس انك هتاخد 12 مليار دولار وانا
هقدم لك بديل ازاي توفر 12 مليار من غير
ما تلجا للايه دي الصندوق
وطبعا ممكن تلجا للصندوق بس مش بالتعويم
ده شرط كان ممكن لو احنا قدمنا حجه لا
ممكن مش بالضروره تعويض هقول له
انا دلوقتي اقدر فاتوره الواردات في ذلك
الحين في 2015 كانت 60 مليار دولار
مجمل ولايات مصر كاستمرار قلت له لو انا
خفضت الوردات بتاعتي بنسبه معقوله 20%
يعني دولار من بين كل خمسه دولار
هعمل كم بقى خمس ستين 12 مليار ده المبلغ
اللي هديه لك لايه لكن هيخلق واقرا مختلف
تماما انك انت مش هتكون ملزم بتعويم
الجنيه وبالتالي سعر الجنيه بعد ما كان
تمانيه تسعه جنيه مع للدولار الامريكي وصل
ل 18 و19
وزلزل الاسعار فاصبح عندك تضخم وصل في
مرحله المائله 70% في حاجه فظيعه جدا
ومعدل الفقر زائد اشياء كثيره جدا عايز
اقوله انه يعني اوكي الى ان يتم تغيير
اليات عمل هذه المؤسسات التي اشرت اليها
لما نوصل لمرحله نظام جديد
اتعامل مع دي ولكن اشوف المساحه اللي ممكن
اتحرك فيها عشان اقابل بعض الشروط وارفض
بعض الشروط الاخرى انما مثلا بالنسبه
للجنيه قلت الموضوع مش من قبيل يعني
التمدرس في المواقع لا طبعا بقاء الحاله
على ما هو عليه بالنسبه غير مقبول لك
اقتصادي يعني من غير انه مقاومه باكثر بين
قيمته مزبوط لذلك قلت يا جماعه انه احنا
دلوقتي رابطين الجنيه بالدولار
وده يعني اما تعبير عن قله الحيله او على
الكسل المهني الشديد او عن صوره ذهنيه انا
حاسين ان ده المركب العتيد جدا ان الشعبط
فيه عشان يوصلنا
وانا ارفض هذه التصورات الثلاثه وبقول انه
المفروض انا اربط عملتي
بسله عملات تنطقع بما يخدم مصلحتي الوطنيه
اقتصاديه ويعبر عن شركه تعاملات
الاقتصاديه على مستوى العالم مش الدولار
طبعا الدولار هيبقى جزء منها ولكن بدل ما
يكون وزنه ميه في الميه وباقي العملات صفر
على الشمال هيبقى وزنه قول 30% 40 25 دي
بتتحسب بالورقه والقلم بنعمه على علاقات
التجاريه
الاتحاد كمثال العلاقات التجاريه مع
امريكا
علي من 20% يعني حجم تعاملاتنا وامريكا ما
تشوف وارداتنا من امريكا قد ايه ورداتنا
من العالم دي تطلع حوالي 18% اتحاد
الاوروبي هو اهم شريك فين عمله اتحاد
الاوروبيه مش موجوده انا بحدد سعر حاليا
نظام الحالي بحدد علاقه الجنيه المصري
باليورو
عن طريق علاقه الدولار
فبيخلع مواقف مضحكه جدا هقول لك ممكن يبقى
في عجز في منطقه اليورو في مواجهه
الولايات المتحده
فينتج عن هذا انه يتراجع امام الدولار
وبما انه جنيه مربوط بالدولار فليورو
يتراجع امام الجنيه المصري في الوقت اللي
انا عندي عجز كبير ومتزايد مش منطقي
الكلام انما ناتج عن الاتحاد الاوروبي في
الوقت اللي عندي فيه انا عجزه
يعني فالمفروض ان اليورو يرتفع مش كده ولا
ايه فتلاقوا انا عندي الارقام
بيتراجع قدام الجنيه لان اليورو يتراجع
قدام الدولار والجنيه المصري مربوط
بالدولار
فده وضع يعني مؤذي اقتصاديا بالنسبه
وبالتالي عايز اقول سله عملات ده اللي
لازم ده اللي انا بقوله فيما يتعلق
بالطبعا
معضله المعادلات في تعاملنا مع صندوقنا
الموضوع العجز المالي وده صحيح عجمان ولكن
العجز المقلي وهنا نيجي للصوره اللي ذهنيه
ايضا الصوره الذهنيه دي على فكره مساله
اساسيه جدا عايز يمتاز الفرصه وكل شويه
اركز عليه يعني عندنا صوره زي لان احنا
عندنا يعني محتاجين
لتمويل من الخارج عشان احنا شعب فقير خلاص
دي صوره زي
المقوله خاطئه تماما ليه لانه
انت اهملت الادخار واحنا في زمن الناس فيه
بتتنفس الدين واصبح متدين
عايز اقول فضيله الزهد قيمه الزهد كقيمه
دينيه
اما تاخد بلدنا مش النقطه الرئيسيه انه مش
الفقر انما قله الحيله هي السبب حضرتك
بتقول المشكله مش في ان احنا فقراء
المشكله في قله الحيله اعلى ان احنا مثال
بالهند احنا متوازي داخل الفرد في في مصر
الاذان اعلى من متوسط داخل الفرد في الهند
رغم التقدم الاقتصادي لاحرزته الهند في
العشر سنين الاخيره عظيم ولكن
معدل الادخار في الهند
يصل الى حوالي ربع يعني
من الناتج يعني من كل 100
وحده بتنتج في الهند
بيتدخلوا منهم حوالي الربع حوالي 25%
بالتالي بيقدر وجهه للاستثمار ابني بلده
طيب في مصر بقى اللي هي البلد الاغلى معدل
التضخم كام هتذهل
عدد ادخار كامل
7% 8%
واحنا اتعلمنا زي ما كانش في ادخار ما فيش
استثمار طيب انت بقى بتقول اذا انا دلوقتي
عايز استثمر ما لا يقل عن 20%
من الناتج وما عنديش الا سبعه تمانيه في
الميه لازم اقترب يطلع لك حاجه اسمها
الايه الفجوه الخارجيه
الفجوه الداخليه عفوا بين ادخار والثمار
فدي تلزمك انك تخطر شيء تاني لانك انت
برضو الدخار بتاعك ضعيف
بتاخد من الخارج بضايع اكتر وبتدي الخارج
فبيخلق لك عجز ايه عجز خريف عجز داخلي
وعجز داخلي خارجي والاثنين بيتفاعلوا مع
بعض مظبوط
هنا بقى بتيجي الموضوع العجز الموازم
الدوري العام للدوله وتدخل في كلام مع
الصندوق الخبراء الصندوق يقول لك ايه نشوف
مش هقول سميته هم شايفين كويس قوي وما
عندوش مشكله في الرؤيه بس هو في تحايز
عنده ليه لانه لما يجي الخبراء بتوعنا
يتفاوضوا معهم يقولوا ده مشكلتك نتيجه انك
دعم عالي فلازم تخفض الايه
خلي بالك من الصوره الذهنيه هنا
بتاعه هو بيقول ليه لان هو عايز في
النهايه لما تخفض الدعم بتخفض دور الحكومه
على طول
وده ترجمه بتاعته عظيم انما لما بتيجي بص
بقى للواقع عندنا هتجد هنا في الحقيقه
الدعم لا يمثل الا كسر بسيط جدا في معادله
الموازنه العامه للدوله في جانب الانفاق
الدعم حاليا
اقل من 15% من الانفاق في المواد العامه
الدوله
وما يزيد عن 80% من الانفاق عباره عن
مدفوعات خدمه الدين فوائد واثار
بس طبعا لان هو موضوع الدين ده بتاعه هو
مش ممكن
عايز اقول يعني وانت بتتناقش مع استنى هنا
دلوقتي
الموضوع مش موضوع دعم
وانفاق حكومه على تعليم احنا انفاق
الحكومه على التعليم والصحه في حديه
الادنى رغم كل ما حدث من تطور بالذات في
مجال الصحه
فاذا ما تقدرش انسانيا تنزله عن هذا
المستوى ما تقدرش عمليا تنزل الدعم عن هذا
المستوى طب اذا كان الموضوع كده وانت تقنع
الخبراء الصندوق بالموضوع
يقول لك خلاص ممكن يعني نسمع كلامك على
الدقيق على الديون
خلينا نتكلم
لف مفتوح ممكن الكلام فيه بدل ما انه
مقفول بالضب ومفتاح لانه كل قصه احاله الى
ما يسمى الخطوط الدعم والانفاخ الحكومه طب
هل لانه يعني طبعا الاقتصاديين فاهمين
كلام حضرتك كويس بس ممكن في جمهور تبقى
المساله بالنسبه لهم ايه مربكه شويه احنا
اللي عارفينه كالاتي يعني ان الصندوق
بيقول لك انت عندك ازمه انا ما خلقتلكش
انت عاوز مساعدتي انت عاوز مساعدتي فانا
هقدم لك قرض والقرض لازم اخده بسرده بنسبه
الفائده البسيطه وهساعدك انك تاخد قروض
اخرى من السوق باي نسب انت تتفق عليها
مبدئيا علشان نقول بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم
انك انت لازم تقلل نفقاتك وتقليل النفقات
مش هيكون من اموال الدائنين لان انت دي
فلوس اقترضتها وهي ليست صدقه فمش هنقترب
منها فانت لازم تقلل نفقاتك ولازم تزود
دخلك بالضرايب والرسوب الى اخره ومن
المنطقي جدا انك تخفض الجنيه ومن المنطقي
لما تخفض الجنيه اولا هتقلل دعمك
الدولارات مش هتروح للجنيه هتروح لحاجات
اهم ثانيا ان منتجك الوطني اذا كان موجود
يعني هيبقى اكثر تنافسيه بدل ما انتج
الالم بعشره هنتجه
برقم اقل يعني بالنسبه للدول المستورده
المفروض ان ده على الورق مش وحش يعني
ده كلام الكتاب
وحش لا كتاب مش وحش انما الواقع شيء مختلف
خلينا نتوقف مثلا لما نيجي لموضوع اه انت
يعني انت اقترضت المفروض تدفع صح اه طبعا
مسؤوليه بالنسبه لنا انا لازم مسؤول عن
تصرفاتك ولكن هنا نرجع لبنيه النظام
الدولي خلي
بالك السيد الاقتصادي العالم هل هو
الولايات المتحده قرر لحساباته ان يرفع
سعر الفائده
على طول ده يضغط عليك انت عشان ترفع سعر
الفائده او تاخد اجراء اللي هو تسد الباب
قدام رؤوس الاموال الساخنه عشان ما تعملكش
مشكله بس كنت انت ملتزم بحريه حركه روسيا
واعملها جوز مهم من محددات السياسه بتاعتك
يبقى مع كل رفع لسعر الفايده يجريه بنك
الاحتياطي الفيدرالي في امريكا لازم انت
واحنا شفنا الكلام ده خلال السنه
مضبوط فاذا في مساله تتعلق بالبنيه النظام
اللي انا اتكلمت عنها اذا انت عايز تظبط
امورك بحيث تبقى اقل خضوعا
لضغط نظام الدوري ممكن في حاجات تعملها
دي واحد اتنين انه بالنسبه للتخفيض اه خفض
فانتاجك يبقى اكثر تنافسيه مع الورق ولكن
الواقع المصري انت عندك
هيكل اقتصادي
نسبه معتبره من الانتاج في الداخل
يعتمد على مكونات مستورده صحيحه فاذا في
الوقت اللي صحيح بيديك ميزه كمصدر في
ارتفاع في تكلفه الانتاج لانه مكونات
الانتاج المستورده لتصبح اعلى مع كل تخفيض
في قيمه العمله فمش قادره نفس فمش
وبالتالي هنا المنظور من زاويتين مهم جدا
من زاويه انك انت بتتعامل مع هيكل للهيمنه
محدد للنظام العالمي الحالي
صحيح انت مش تقدر يعني تواجه ميه في الميه
مره واحده انما تقدر من خلال فهم من بين
الطرف التاني ان انت فاهم الكلام دوت وان
التصرف في الاداره الامريكيه غير مسؤول
حقيقه لان هي بتستغل سلطتها في مجال اصدار
البنك نوت للعالم اللي هو الدولار في انها
تؤذي كل خلق الله بهذه الطريقه عظيم فاذا
لانه كمان مع كل رفع في سعر الفائده
بترتفع قيمه الدولار الامريكي لانه مخزن
افضل قيمه ومع ارتفاع قيمه الدولار
الامريكي
اذا الموضوع فانت عندك شبكه زي ايه
البلوفر التريكو كده كل حته فيه ماسكه في
حته تانيه دي نقطه النقطه الثانيه
ان انت بقى كسلان بالمناسبه
يعني صندوق النقل الدولي لم يفرض علينا ان
احنا نفتح الباب على اسرائيل لرؤوس
الاموال الساخنه
الناس فاهمه غير كده والمسؤولين عندنا
فاهمين كده الكلام ده غير صحيح يعني لما
تقرا الدستور بتاع منظمه بتاع صندوق النقد
اللي هي حاجه اسمها اتفاقيه الصندوق
صدرت امتى في 44 واتعدلت 20 مره وهتتعدل
كمان
وكان قبل ما تنطلق ازمه دول شرق اسيا في
سنه تسعينات تسعينات كان الصندوق بيحارجم
وناوي على انه يغير الاتفاقيه بحيث يحط
فيها شرط انه الاعضاء يلتزم بتخفيض
المعاملات الراسماليه
عفوا بتحرير المعاملات الراسماليه الجاريه
اللي هي رؤوس الاموال انه يسمح بتدفق رؤوس
اموال ساكنه اكثر تدخل وتخرج
ولكن لما اندلعت الازمه كان احد اسبابها
ولا زال الوضع كما هو عليه وبالتالي انا
مش ملزق في الواقع ان انا اسيب الباب
لرؤوس الاموال الساخنه تيجي تقعد عندي
ثلاث اشهر اربع اشهر ست اشهر سنه وتروح
خارجه انا باسرار الجراد لانه في الواقع
لما بتخرج بتسيب الدنيا غير ما لقيتها لما
بتدخل انت مش ملزم انت مضطر هو محدش قال
لك ملزم بس المفروض ان انت انت محتاج
دولار مش قادر تنتج علشان
تحصل على دولار ده الفكر عفوا اللي انا
عايز اتحداه في الواقع اللي هو منطلق
الصوره هنا يؤسفني جدا انا اشوف في الحاله
المصريه
الامر اختزل الى انه حاجه اسمها الدولار
وانت عايز تدبره باي طريقه باي طريقه
واحيانا بنصل الى يعني امور يؤسفنا قلنا
مخزيه
مخزيه انك انت تقول للناس اللي هم سووا
موقفكم التجنيدي وادفعولنا قد كده صح
اشتري مش عارف فيزا وبتاعه تعال اشتري
كلام مش دي اداره اقتصاد دي اداره اقرب
اداره الدكان وبالتالي انا عايز اقول في
منطق وفي فكر ورا
صندوق النقل الدولي وخبراءه
وانا بقول اوكي لا يفل للحديد الحديد الا
الحديد انا عايز يبقى عندي فكر ومنطق
يواجه فكره منطقي الصندوق وهنا محتاج
تغيير الصوره الذهنيه طالما طول ما انا
بنظر الى خبراء الصندوق ويملكه الحكمه
والخبره وفاهمين الدنيا شكلها ايه يبقى
انا اميلاني اتقبل الكلام بتاعهم لما يقول
لي خفض الجناوي
قلت لك اهو انا دبرت لك 12 مليار دولار
باجراء من حقك طبقا لناصت فئه الجد وتقدر
ترجع لمنظام تجاره العاميه وتعمل وفي بلاد
عملت الكلام
ده بس هي برضو الانطلاق واحد اتنين نقطه
مهمه جدا
لابد ان يكون لديك انت كبلد الشخص المناسب
في المقام المناسب
بمعنى انه
ما تيجي لمؤسسه شديده في خطوره زي البنك
المركزي
لابد ان يكون على راسه
اللي بنسميه المحافظ محافظ البنك
شخصيه اقتصاديه من العيار الثقيل
ما ينفعش بانكير
خالص ليه لان ده البنك المسؤول عن
الاقتصاد وتوازنات كلها وبالتالي فكر
البنكري يجي في جزئيه صغيره
متفرعه عن مجمل الصوره الاقتصاديه
ولو تبص في كل دول العالم خد الحاله
الامريكيه الاقتصاديين على اعلى مستوى انت
يعني لا مؤاخذه جايب مصرفي وحطه مش الحالي
بس واللي قبليه كمان نفس القصه وانت معتقد
انه الخلفيات المصرفيه لا تصلح لقياده
المركزي لسبب لانه لما تقرا قانون البنك
المركزي تعرف انه البنك المركزي سهى هو
اسمه البنك لكن في الواقع هو الكيان
المسؤول عن اداره الاقتصاد
وبالذات في مجال تعاملات مع الخارج
وتوازنته في الداخل وفي كل بلاد
الممارسه تمت على اساس انه تجيب اقتصادي
في بلاد بتلاقيه اقتصادي على مستوى بلادها
بتجيب
برضو بنفس الشخص ومناسبه مناسب وزاره
الماليه وزاره الماليه لا يمكن الا ان
يكون
لا يمكن
انت الاقتصادي المرتبطه زي الضرائب مثلا
او الماليه العامه بتعتبروش اقتصادي لا دي
حاجات تفريعات التطبيق انما انت بتتكلم
على ايه القوانين اللي بتحكم حركه
الاقتصاد
في الداخل
وتفاعلاته مع الخارج
كيف تفهم هذه القوانين وكافه تستخدمها في
الابحار الامن
في
خضم العولمه اللي احنا اشرنا عليها عايز
اقتصادي طب هل ممكن يا معالي الدكتور
ونستكمل في حلقه اخرى بحيث ان احنا نبقى
وصلنا لفكره حضرتك بوضوح
اذا طرحت عليك السؤال التقليدي في عجاله
ثم نفصله في حلقات اخرى
اذا كان لحضرتك في وضع صانع القرار ونحن
في المازق الحالي مش بنتكلم نبدا من
سكراتش يعني احنا موجودين في ازمه في راي
حضرتك ماذا يجب على صانع القرار ان يفعله
عشان يتجاوز الازمه الاقتصاديه الحاليه
ولا يعود اليها بشكل متكرر تبقى زي نزلات
البرد كل شهرين يعني دي طبعا في عجاله
ونرجع للتفاصيل
في النزعه في التوجه يعني ان انا
يعني انت ذكرت لك والله انا يعني مديحه صح
انا حاسس ان انا محتاج انا اخرج ما اكون
من غير ما يقول لي الصندوق هذا الكلام
بنعمله حاليا اذا العنوان الكبير برنامج
للتقشف
برنامج للتقشف التفاصيل كتير في الموضوع
انما البرنامج ليه بقى الاتقاش معناه لو
انت قررت تقشف وخدت اجراء
الانفاق نفسه انخفض نزل من مستوى غير
المستوى دي نقطه الاولى وبالتالي لحقت الى
الاقتراض
النقطه الثانيه انك انت
لازم تحط نظام ونظام صارم جدا للارويات
الاكثر اهميه
بناء على اعتبارات بعضها سياسي والبعض
الاخر اقتصادي نظام
[موسيقى]
نمره ثلاثه
انا دلوقتي عايز اوصل للمستوى للانفاق الى
مستوى تاني عظيم فانا قلت تقشف على سبيل
المثال
تقاشف معروف خلاص انا بقول الاولويات ايه
حضرتك بتقول يجب ان يكون
تاخد القطاعات الاقتصاديه وتدي اهميه من
الدرجه الاولى
واكرر من الدرجه الاولى للزراعه والصناعه
قطعاني لا ثالث له الباقي يجي وراهم اللي
هم القطاع
المهملتين مهملين بطريقه يعني مقلقه انها
بالنسبه لموضوع الاغلبيه ايضا لازم تحط
اولويات بالنسبه لما يسمى المشروعات
القوميه
مش هنعوز القوميه انت فاتح الاجابه عريضه
جدا من المشروعات
[موسيقى]
من يعنيه الامر منع الامر ممكن ممر
بالعمال ممكن الجماهير بشكل
النقابات الى اخره دي مساله اذا اعطيت
حريه الابداء الراي يعني مع ده موضوع يعني
احنا طبعا اعتقد هنجيله في مرحله ما لانه
عشان ما يسمى الاستدامه في الاصلاح
والتقدم
لابد يبقى عند الحكومه وتاخد قرار ظهير من
الشارع او الناس انجاز التعبير او راي
العام خلينا نسميها هراء الاهم ده محتاج
لاهليه للتواصل المستمر
اولا للتاكد من القرار اتخذ قرار يلقى
قبول من اللي ينفذه في النهايه ثانيا
للتاكد ده اصعب القارات التي تم التوصل له
وبالتالي تتحاشى تحمل تكاليف
بلا داعي له
ربنا يخليك يا معالي الدكتور
واستاذنك يكون الحوار بيننا موصول
لاستئناف حلقتنا العنوانها الرئيسي افكار
الاستاذ شكرا جزيلا لحضرتكم